Clothes not being in every single person size
is very much of this video off by saying,
I really do like and respect Leah,
I do think that this video shows a very fundamental misunderstanding
of what the actual
issue is. So I want to push back at some of the points that you made.
I hope you can understand where I'm coming from.
Show this video off by saying,
not every brand needs to make everything for everyone.
And on the surface, yes,
I agree. But this push for inclusivity is not about one specific brand.
It's about brands as a whole
being more inclusive and including more people in their size ranges.
You say if a brand doesn't have your size,
to go where they have your size,
but, like, that's the problem.
We don't have that option.
I can count on my fingers
what stores actually make plus size clothes that are available to me.
I can't shop at a place that doesn't exist.
List of places that I
can shop at has definitely increased over the years,
but it is still not nearly close enough to reflect
the actual population of plus size people in this country.
Two thirds of United States women are considered plus size.
Like, the average clothing size is a 1618,
meaning the average women cannot shop at stores.
Out of all clothing brands in the United States,
only 19% of them carry plus sizes.
And of those 19%,
the majority only up To a 3 x.
So there's an even smaller amount of, like,
companies that carry above a size 3 x.
Last I checked,
between 66 and 72% of United States women are considered plus size.
This lack and gap of available clothing doesn't affect, like,
a small group of people.
This is a very millions.
Millions of women are affected by this.
Compare it to being a size 16 shoe, and, like,
obviously you're not gonna get mad
at companies who don't cater to your shoe size,
but it's a false equivalent
because a sheer amount of people that are affected
by the lack of sizing is, like, much,
much greater. Last fashion week, I had a similar conversation.
I was talking to someone
who said that they thought that brands were forced to be inclusive.
Um, like,
that's just not the reality.
Fashion Week point nine % of the models were plus size.
And again, that's the smallest end of plus sizes.
Not even a full percent of the models.
And 99, over 99% of the models were straight size.
They were skinny.
No one is being forced to do anything.
Push towards inclusivity is happening from consumers
because we're telling companies what we want and what we need.
But, like, there's no gun to anyone's head.
Like, at that is ultimately their choice
just as much as our choice and prerogative
to be able to speak about it.
And I think because it's a conversation that we have primarily online,
A perception that we have access to much more than we actually do.
But when you look at this,
when you look at the less than 1% of models were plus,
and that less than 19% of clothing retail,
supposedly
supposed to cater to two thirds of the entire population of women,
how that number has been decreasing since covid,
we see that just not the case.
Still not being included again.
So I'm a follower of yours,
so I know that you previously were fat,
and you put a lot of work into it,
and you care very much about maintaining a certain,
you know, look now.
And your body and your health are very important to you,
which is totally awesome for you.
I'm in no way criticizing.
Think everyone should be able to do what they want with their body.
That being said,
that the clothes weren't flattering.
It was a body that was a flatter,
which obviously I can't change your opinion on your body.
As a person with a fat body,
some people may think is unflattering.
Can tell you that there are still clothes that look good
and are flattering on my body.
And there's a very big difference between the way that I look and feel
are created with a fat body in mind.
The way that I feel with clothes are ill fitting
and not made with fat bodies in mind.
With your personal journey to weight loss,
you no longer feel The effects of fat phobia.
And you may think that's a solution for everyone,
it's not. Even if tomorrow every single person on the planet decided,
I'm gonna lose weight,
I'm gonna go on weight loss journey,
people would still be fat.
And what are they supposed to do in the meantime?
The time when we have conversations about fat people,
the dominant narrative,
if we are talking about fatphobia,
we experience is to just lose weight,
and then that phobia will disappear.
And we also may save an individual from experiencing fatphobia.
But it doesn't change the lived experience
for every other fat person on the planet.
It doesn't change the fact that there are still fat people that exist.
There are still fat people that deserve to wear clothes
that make them feel good.
You shouldn't have to lose weight to have access to clothes.
I'm not saying every single brand needs to include up,
but also more brands than currently do should also make sizes for us.
A lot of time people are talking about department store,
not like luxury brand.
Like, obviously, again,
they're all included in the same conversation.
I live in New York City,
right? The center of everything.
There are three stores in the city.
If I had to put clothing on my body,
does not even my style,
just clothing on my body,
I would be able to go out and buy that.
You say being a human being is a beautiful thing.
And we shouldn't waste our time with useless nonsense.
But I'll push back and say to me, fashion isn't useless.
It may be a minute thing to you,
but as someone who spent my entire adolescence
shopping at Macy's and Walmart,
buying ugly, ill fitting clothing that further isolated me from my peer,
that reminded me every single day
that I was different from everyone else
and constantly made me feel like there was something wrong with.
That wasn't a small thing.
First time I stepped into a tour
and bought a bra that I thought was cute and fashionable and trend,
I cried in that dressing room.
Memory of that experience is like a flash bulb in my mind
because it was so impactful.
Because my entire life
I had gone without feeling good in the clothes that I wore.
And finally we're at a point where there is more options,
yes, for inclusive sizing. Again, it's.
It's still a very small amount.
Getting access to clothing that fit me and I thought was cute,
fundamentally change my life.
Cause the way that I move to the world,
the way that I feel about my body is impacted by the clothes I wear.
Because if I'm leaving the house in an outfit that I feel good
and that I feel stylish in,
that I feel fashionably,
I feel more confident and happy in my being able to wear clothes
that make you feel good about yourself.
I don't think It's a small thing.
It took me a long time to get to a point in my life where I'm
comfortable in my body
and I don't hate myself
and hate what I see in the mirror every single day.
Was the way that I dress
and finally being able to start wearing clothing that I,
you know, I think is cute.
That's only been able to happen
because of this push towards inclusivity.
But again, the options that we have are very limited.
I'm able to make it work with what we have,
but it takes a lot of time,
money, and privilege to be able to be fat and look cute and, like,
be fashionable.
That should be something that I think everyone deserves access to.
It's not just about the clothes.
It's about, like,
being humanized,
but being seen and being considered as people.
You know, when I go shopping with my thin friends
and I enter a store that doesn't have my side,
I'm not gonna say anything,
but when I walk into the store,
I am reminded that I am not considered,
not wanted, and not welcome.
Looks well. I do shop at
and support the companies that do support me and make clothes for me.
I don't think it's wrong to want more and to desire more,
and to think that, at the very least,
the fashion industry as it exists
should be more reflective of the average consumer,
because ultimately, these brands are Not your friend.
Their only purpose is to make money,
and they don't need you to defend them.
They're going to become more inclusive and listen to
or saying is because we're bitching about it.
Then, like, sorry,
that's working.
I think the lived experience of fat people
should be considered more than
the feelings of a few corporations.
And unless we push forward,
it's not gonna happen.
Which I hope I was able to give you some perspective and, like,
understanding of the issue as a whole
and why we care so much about pushing for inclusivity
and why it matters so much to us.
I do really respect you.
I just. This take I had to push back on.
This video was educational,
informative, help, just, like,
you know, give you my perfect.
Also, I am more than willing to talk about this more.
I understand that not everybody,
you know, engages in fat politics,
so you might have
spend a lot of time researching and talking about them.
More than willing to,
you know, give you my perspective,
to talk and to educate if you are willing to listen.
And that goes for everyone.
I'm sorry it's such a long video,
but, like, if you have any questions and you are respectful about them,
I would be more than happy to, like,
give you more information and,
you know, my perspective.
I hope the comments are respectful and understanding and empathetic,
and I hope you guys are Open enough to,
you know, maybe
see a different perspective that you didn't agree with previously.